bonjour pour le mois d'octobre les
autres créatrices du tube et moi même
avions proposé le thème d'halloween en
personne original que nous sommes on est
déjà début décembre mais c'est pas grave
c'est ça la liberté d'halloween j'ai
dévié vers les sorcières que j'ai déjà
commencé à inventer dans ma vidéo sur
l'inquisition
si vous ne l'avez pas vu va apparaître
sur le canapé vous pouvez cliquer et les
sorcières étant un sujet très large j'ai
décidé de vous présenter une facette des
croyances les concernant à savoir le
salon alors pour commencer vous avez pu
remarquer que le mot sabah est issu du
mot shabbat qui est un rite religieux
juifs et ça n'est pas un hasard puisque
à l'époque où les sorcières commence à
être poursuivi ou les premiers ouvrages
de démonologie voit le jour les juifs
sont également mal considérée en france
dans certains ouvrages de démonologie le
sabbat est également appelée synagogues
des sorcières ce qui renforce le lien
avec le judaïsme le sabbat est une
réunion nocturne entre les sorcières et
le diable avec qui elles ont passé un
pacte
en effet la croyance admise est que le
diable a été autorisé par dieu à tenter
les humains et conclus avec certains
surtout des femmes des pactes satanique
pour composer une société secrète qui se
réunit lors de saba et complotent à
détruire l'ordre naturel des choses
le diable disposerait de plusieurs
pouvoirs listées dans les ouvrages de
démonologie comme celui de jantes
actrice selon lui le diable peut faire
apparaître des serpents commandait la
pluie le vent le tonnerre les tempêtes
porter les gens en l'air et les faire
voler ce qui est très intéressant
puisque d'après ses croyances ne sont
pas les sorcières qui volent n'ont pas
le pouvoir mais c'est le diable qui le
leur permet il peut également rompre les
serrures emporté ce qui est dans les
coffres et bien sûr tenter les gens par
contre il ne serait pas capable de
transformer un homme en bête on ne peut
pas être bon partout de grands s'abat en
dieu à certaines dates précises qui
correspondent au rythme des saisons et à
la culture agraire le 1er mai et le 1er
novembre par exemple pour les autres ça
bah on n'est pas sur des joueurs choisy
ça pourrait être le mercredi et le
vendredi pour certains mais tous les
auteurs ne sont pas d'accord comment se
déroule un bon sabah concrètement je
tiens ici à rappeler même si ça peut
sembler évident
les descriptions qui vont suivre nous
montre les croyances du xvème xvième
siècle issues des traités de démonologie
et des procès de sorcellerie
d'abord la sorcière est chez elle lui et
elle s'ennuie d'un onguent sur tout le
corps avant d'avaler une poudre à base
de belladone pourquoi me direz-vous
parce que c'est de la drogue à partir de
là on peut donner raison à tout et
n'importe quoi après avoir avalé sa dose
elle prend son envol sur un bâton ou un
balai en passant par sa cheminée
l'antithèse du père noël en quelque
sorte en volant elle rejoint le lieu du
sabbat qui peut être dans une clairière
un carrefour
en tout cas dans un endroit désert ou
bien un lieu où se trouveraient des
pierres datant de l'époque néolithique
comme ça on garde un lien avec les
religions païennes je reviendrai là
dessus ensuite il existe dans des tas de
région des lieux où selon les légendes
locales les sorcières se rassembler pour
le symbole le bastberg en alsace la
langue de carnac en bretagne
le sommet du puy de dôme en auvergne ou
blackpool à en suède arrivée sur place
elle retrouve une foule très disparate
allant des nobles souvent masqués à deux
petits enfants qui ferait pâture et des
crapauds bons jours neuville on entend
un orchestre selon les témoignages
discordants ou harmonieux on s'échange
des recettes de potions et le sort puis
la messe est célébrée à rebours est
présidé par le diable en personne pour
communier on prenait à la place de
l'austin une robe noire selon certains
témoignages le diable prendrait la forme
d'un book pour d'autres ce serait un
chat noir dont les sorcières devrait
embrasser l'anus en arrivant au sabbat
la mise après la messe se dérouler un
banquier de mai soit délicieux soit
largement périmés là encore les
témoignages divergent
en tout cas on ne consomme rien de sale
et si vous connaissez les frères
winchester vous comprendrez pourquoi le
sel et le diable ne font pas bon ménage
ensuite c'est l'orgie entre le diable et
les sorcières rassembler durant laquelle
elle lui confesse toutes les mauvaises
actions et l'essor qu'elles sont jetés
dans cette représentation inversé de la
justice divine
le diable récompense les sorcières les
plus mauvaises et punis celles qui ne
sont pas allées assez fort qui craignent
encore trop l'église on danse aussi
beaucoup toute la nuit jusqu'au chant du
coq ou soudain tout disparaît les
sorcières se réveille chez elle où elles
reprennent leur vie jusqu'au saab à
suivre pour certains théologiens cessa
bas n'ont pas lieu dans notre monde mais
en songe et la sorcière n'a jamais pris
son envol sur un balai pour se rendre au
lieu du sabbat ce sont simplement les
drogues qu'elle avait prises qui lie en
anglais mais sanaa des inculpés pas pour
autant on peut voir dans l'imaginaire du
sabbat une référence bacchanales des
fêtes religieuses gréco romaine où l'on
célébrait le dieu de dionysos ou bacchus
pour les romains et donc la picole la
picole la picole la picole en effet le
sabbat est une construction des
théologiens dans laquelle elle réactive
des croyances anciennes telles que les
fêtes païennes des personnes qui avouent
avoir participé au sabbat sous la
torture répondent aux questions très
précises des juges
ce sont ces derniers qui fournissent les
précisions des monologique la sorcière
commence par devoir raconter
l'initiation diabolique concrétisée par
la marque la copulation avec le diable
puis le sabbat et enfin la liste des
torts aux maléfices qu'elle a commis
dans certains pays comme le danemark
il n'y a pas de mythe du sabbat malgré
l'existence de procès de sorcellerie
même si on mettait le diable de côté les
historiens qui soutiennent la réalité du
sabbat sont donc très rare alexandrie
entre dans son histoire de la
philosophie occulte dit cette phrase
très évocatrice il n'y avait
probablement pas de saba dans cette
région le pays basque avant l'arrivée de
lancre conseiller au parlement de
bordeaux
tout au plus quatre fêtes saisonnières
auquel une fille du confesse d'être allé
dès qu'il commence son office
d'inquisiteur il y en a un tous les
lundis puis toutes les nuits et
peut-être que quelques-uns ont été
organisées réellement par défi dans le
sabbat les théologiens font passer tout
ce qu'ils voudraient voir rejeter les
activités nocturnes et fait un peu trop
olé olé l'obscurité et le domaine du
diable pour les théologiens uniquement
alors qu'elle est très animé
n'est pas toujours craintes dans les
campagnes de l'époque des bandes de
jeunes célibataires s'y promènent bois
font la fête des monologues ont pu
croire y voir des sabbats ou essayé
d'interdire ces divertissements
nocturnes par le biais des procès de
sorcellerie ainsi peuple et la nuit de
démons et de sorcières peut être un bon
moyen de dissuader les jeunes d'aller se
promener à moins que ça leur donne des
idées
la prochaine fois on se retrouvera pour
du chronique de profs
j'ai pas encore décidé du sujet mais ce
dont quelques recherches en cours
d'ici là portez vous bien continuer de
vous intéresser à l'histoire aux revers
[Musique]